we gotta find our way out of here
you want to tell me where the hell we're
going
Manhattan
Jesus Christ
can you at least tell me what the hell
you are doing out here a few weeks back
I got raided
they took your kid
thank you
have you seen this man goes by the name
of Negan
how do I figure into this Maggie
the man who's got her show you know him
you need me
is on the island
[Music]
we don't know you we get on the island
you don't get off
he makes sure of that it's the real
reason we're here so you want to go to
the cycle that we can help you with
foreign
what the hell is that
I don't know why you with that man I'm
looking for but I will get to you
the ending is all that matters
I think you're gonna like it here
little stranger